RIPPED FROM TODAY'S INTERNET
HEADLINES, IT'S "RAPID REFRESH."
>>"BATMAN: ARKHAM KNIGHT IS THE
LATEST INSTALLMENT OF THE
BLOCKBUSTER VIDEO FRANCHISE. IT
CAME OUT TUESDAY IN CASE YOU ARE
WONDERING WHY THE NERDS IN YOUR
LIFE AREN'T RESPONDING TO TEXTS.
IT'S THE FIRST GAME IN THE
SERIES WHERE YOU CAN DRIVE THE
( BLEEP ) BATMOBILE.
YOU KNOW YOUR STANDARD STAPLE OF
VILLAINS. YOU GOT YOUR JOKER,
YOUR PENGUIN, YOUR RIDDLER. BUT
AS THEY KEEP MAKING MORE AND
MORE OF THESE GAMES, THE BATMAN
ROGUES GALLERY IS GETTING
STRETCHED PRETTY THIN.
SO PANELISTS, WHAT'S A LAME
BATMAN VILLAIN MIGHT
WE SEE IN THE FUTURE?
>> THE TICKLER.
>> CHRIS: THAT WOULD DRIVE ME
CRAZY.
I CANNOT STAND TO BE TICKLED.
NOT EVEN FUN.
>>HE JUST PINS YOU DOWN AND--
>>CHRIS: NO! THAT WOULD BE THE--
RYAN?
>> HARLEY QUINN, MEDICINE WOMAN.
>>CHRiS: YES, OH MY GOD, IT WAS
RIGHT THERE THE WHOLE TIME.
MOVING ON. R&B HAS A RICH AND
OILY TRADITION OF SEXUALLY
SUGGESTIVE TITLES, LIKE "LET'S
GET IT ON" AND "SEXUAL
HEALING" AND THE '90s SLOW
JAM THROWBACK GINUWINE
HAS RELEASED A NEW SONG THAT
GIVES A HEARTY MIDDLE FINGER TO
SUBTLETY.
COMING SOON TO A FILTHY AIRPORT
ADJACENT STRIP CLUB NEAR
YOU-- "LEAVE IT IN."
WHY NOT JUST LEAVE IT IN THE
WHOLE TIME?
HERE'S A FUN FACT-- GINUWINE HAS
EIGHT KIDS HIMSELF.
SO MAYBE THE NEXT ONE SHOULD BE
CALLED "YANK IT OUT," OR "FINISH
IN HER HAIR FOR A CHANGE."
COMEDIANS, WHAT'S AN EVEN LESS
SUBTLE TITLE FOR AN R&B SLOW JAM
THAN "LEAVE IT IN"?
ASHLEY.
>> WHO'S DICK IS THIS? IT'S
MINE.
IT'S NOT DONE YET.
>> SHE'S GOT MORE.
>> I GOT MORE!
IT'S "WHO'S DICK IS THIS?
IT'S MINE, AND SOON IT WILL BE
YOURS, GIRL"
>> CHRIS: YES, ALL RIGHT, GOOD,
POINTS.
I FEEL LIKE THAT--
>> I JUST NEEDED TO SAY THE
FIRST PART.
>> CHRIS: THAT'S IF A DICK YOU
DIDN'T RECOGNIZE TEXTED YOU.
"WHO'S DICK IS THIS?"